hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to alice is dead not so
wonderful look into the world of Alice
in Wonderland now this is a
point-and-click style adventure horror
game that came out on Newgrounds a few
years back and apparently it's
incredibly highly rated and well loved
and I never played it but thank you
everybody who suggested this game and
buckle up and get ready to go down the
rabbit hole now I'm wondering if this
game is gonna be in any way related to
the book Who am I Who am I I don't know
oh hey how's it going don't mind me I'm
just shouting questions to the air it's
not gonna bother you at all lovely bug
crawling down the front of your dress
that's wonderful is that Alice I'm
assuming it says drink me but it's empty
damn I don't know why I'm upset about
that what did I want to slug it down oh
it's only a few feet away from a rotting
corpse I'm sure it was filled with happy
juice great yeah watch oh she isn't
using it anymore
whoops I guess Alice won't mind unless
she's gonna wake up and be a zombie kill
the wabbit kill the wabbit kill although
Elmer Fudd anyone am i holding here oh
hey oh oh Alice forgot to put on makeup
hey that's a little rude I think she's
beautiful
au naturale Alice doesn't smile as much
as she used to what are you talking
about
she's got a huge grin on her face oh
this is silly oh hey you're looking at
me now oh oh oh she's got a bug crawling
up her 400 it just crawled outta one
aisle and into another great I'm so
happy for her I'm gonna go now unless
there's something else hi no matter how
hard you push her pull the don't we're
door won't open
well how about I take the hinges off and
then I'd be smart about this I'm an
engineer I actually don't know who I am
am I the weapon oh hey what
lovely
you what what are you talking about
boogeyman song okay whatever a big stick
nice great I got a big sick I can beat
away the shambling corpse of Alice right
by me oh okay
everything's fine apparently she's got
to listen to this music okay
I'm at with these point-and-click
adventure games there's always a lot of
hidden stuff in the way okay wait yes
you broke a shovel your parents must be
proud I don't know who I am
how am I gonna know what my parents want
whatever fine oh this rock could be
useful okay why there's plenty of rocks
I'm in a pit there's nothing but rocks
and dirt I've got lots of dirt have you
seen some dirt
it's everywhere okay so wait why is my
vision shifting like red over here maybe
because I don't like staring at Alice's
dead body
hi can anyone tell me Who am I Who I am
oh no okay I probably shouldn't shout
directly into the microphone it's
probably not pleasant to your ears this
is an ASMR experience oh no that's just
dirt on my monitor what am I talking
about okay so what okay so I can use
items on things the door probably won't
kill the rabbit and you don't know it's
got a talking doorknob maybe I could
coerce it into killing the rabbit for me
own bone is too large to fit in the lock
there's nothing for the door to drink if
it good again stop telling the door what
it can and can't do it's door free will
geez ohms oh oh oh I did a thing you
sharpen the bone using the rough Rock
okay
the bone is too big before yes okay what
why I just unlocked it no matter how
hard you push you pull the board won't
open a balloon or put in one budge hmm
what did it do oh that what Oh
oh I forgot this was Alice in Wonderland
like I was trying to say in the
beginning of this or I don't even know
if I mentioned this the beginning of
this but if you ever watched the movie
Alice in Wonderland which most of you
probably have then you definitely know
or if you've read the book why did they
start with a movie I'm such a dingus
when I tell stories if you've read the
book Alice in Wonderland it is nothing
like the movie which you would already
know if you read the book I'm just gonna
show up because I don't have any
interested in facts for anybody the tree
trunk is filled with acid great maybe I
need more to refuel my adventure I'm on
he's apparently that's definitely what's
happening again is that music getting
louder alright whatever looks like a key
card scanner why would there be a key
card scanner this was like established
way back when I don't even know what
time period Allison Wonderland is
supposed to be but I know it's not
keycard scanner era oh hey this Web is
separating you from the caterpillar
great oh he's got a key oh I'll beat it
I'm gonna stab it I'm gonna kill it
you'll have to get rid of this web first
drink it
oh the acid oh oh wait what was that
what about that sticky tree sap you hold
the bottle under the sample nothing
happens a button stick yeah
wait what oh it's our get the stick has
sticky SAP on it ah it's a stinky stinky
SAP stick okay anyway so the acid
I could probably yeah there we go fill
the bottle with acid and then I can just
melt this caterpillar away you throw the
bottle the bottle broke but the acid
took care of the web and now I just so
happen now this sharp piece of glass hey
the caterpillar is not gonna let you me
pass I can tell you want to kill the
rabbit he ignores the note got Aprilia
laughs as you tried to stab it
caterpillars a sticky caterpillar still
a threat hey I'm just thinking here
you'd have to get close to stabbing can
I can i oh I made a spear good for me
huh how did I stab it in the back of the
hand was I supposed to do that the music
stopped oh I did
I think I did bad maybe a bell I wonder
if it still works
oh it's got a few stab marks in it but
it's not too bad you already killed it
no need to make a bigger mess I didn't
mean to kill it I could have just asked
for the stuff I guess maybe did I kill
Alice it was found right next to the
body I really don't know maybe that is a
thing all righty then
hi okay Alice you still good
oh I can't I can't get close to Alice
anymore
great he doesn't finish law oh come on
uh wait oh whoa oh oh oh oh oh that's
creepy
I'm hungry why just open one the world
kill the rabbit die die oh my god oh no
oh no Alice was trapped here why won't
it open oh I don't know 8ball eat ball
why do I need an eight ball hey I still
hear it meets ooh God oh you mean alice
is trapped in this horrible horrible pit
- it's funny now I think I'm sick I'm
sick
oh my god I'm sick oh that's so horrible
okay do I need to remember these numbers
I got an 8 into - ah I don't think there
was anything else all right cool 8 - 8 -
ah 8 definitely 8 okay - okay all right
8 - Oh what is this I didn't know this
is here oh I don't feel well Oh
9 8 - 9 I think I'll stay home today
what does that mean what do you mean by
that I don't like it here I want to
leave okay I get it okay
8 - 9 - 8 - 9 - oh eh oh eh oh
going there are you doing you want a key
there eight - nine - eight - nine -
eight - nine - you want to kill the
rabbit you know it might crawl on the
paper II why kill a spider it could be
now Oh
caterpillars just deserve to die but
spiders the kindest of all mammals okay
eight - nine - eight - nine - eight -
nine - oh I didn't even know this is
place a strange-looking playing guard
okay eight - nine - I've been bad why no
one knows I've been bad I've been bad is
that me or xenos
oh no eight - nine - uh eight - nine -
OH eight - nine - 0 8 - 9 - 0 3 ok 8 - 9
- 0 3 8 - 9 - 0 3 help me remember
everybody 8 - 9 - 0 3 no I hope me
remember man 8 - 9 - 0 3 oh well that
doesn't help me at all just let me back
to where I was 8 - 9 - 0 3 8 - 9 - 0 3
so what is the playing playing card do
oh the card reader
oh is it brilli would that be the thing
8 - 9 - 0 3 8 - 9 - 0 3 8 - 9 - 0 3
bingo ah ah what Oh
8 Oh - quiet 9 - 0 god damn it don't do
that to me
I open the briefcase you've won what
inside the briefcase is a mere roar
Who am I I located him oh wow
oh no oh no oh yeah oh no come on ah you
can't pull the rug out from under me
when I'm that far into it those is
getting so interesting
oh well good thing this was made in the
past in part two and three I think
there's just a three part series
they're already released so I can play
them at my leisure which I will right
now immediately after this because very
curious about the hell's gonna happen so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other cool coin
click adventure horror game played in
the description below or in the
annotations over there thanks again
everybody
I'll see you
Oh God you're freaking me out man
put your hands go small
Oh Ellis
Oh